en 2015 nous avons annoncé notre feuille
de route depuis cinq ans bientôt nous
sommes allés même au delà
et l'année qui vient de s'écouler
d'ailleurs à montrer la concrétisation
de nombreux des projets annoncés la
fibre partout
nous avions annoncé en janvier dernier
en est l'exemple d'avion premier c'est
chose faite
95% des lignes sont en très haut débit
l'objectif suivant la fibre partout et
pour tous
en 2025 dès cette année les travaux
démarrent dans les zones prioritaires et
dans les dix communes de plus de 3000
habitants
à cela s'ajoute la téléphonie mobile qui
reste un enjeu majeur sur notre
territoire
les premiers pylônes hauts vont être
installés cette année nous devons
absolument répondre aux besoins exprimés
et ainsi anticiper l'arrivée de la 5g la
mobilité est également un point
extrêmement important
nous avons ajouté un plan supplémentaire
spécial grosses réparations de huit
millions et demi d'euros
l'objectif est simple identifier les
points urgent il est nécessaire
d'intervenir
il ne faut plus attendre il ne faut plus
attendre également pour la rd 347
les travaux commenceront cette année par
l'aménagement avait rue en deux fois
deux voies
nous restons entièrement mobilisé pour
l'aménagement de la rn 147 afin de
répondre au mieux aux attentes des
usagers le numérique et la mobilité vont
de pair pour favoriser l'accès à
l'emploi
nous continuerons à suivre les
bénéficiaires du rsa
grâce au forum au plat nous avons
négocié les clauses sociales au travers
des marchés publics avec les entreprises
c'est ainsi qu'un certain nombre
d'heures de travail sont réservés pour
les bénéficiaires du revenu de
solidarité active
ces heurts sont réservés sur les
chantiers des casernes de des centres de
secours et d'incendié l'aréna
futuroscope et le 35e collège c'est un
premier pas pour le retour vers l'emploi
les politiques sociales sont au coeur de
nos compétences en 2019
nous avons adopté un schéma unique des
solides
notre priorité répondre aux besoins des
personnes âgées et des personnes
handicapées en matière de dépendance de
logements de résidence autonomie d pad
tout en limitant le reste à charge pour
les usagers et les familles département
de la vienne mène une action forte en
matière de santé car il n'y a pas de
territoire d'avenir sans professionnels
de santé aujourd'hui grâce aux bourses
d'études
ce sont une trentaine de professionnels
qui sont installés en milieu rural la
tribu ont également une nouvelle aide à
la première installation dans les
secteurs prioritaires et continuons à
aider les installations de maisons de
santé pluridisciplinaires
aujourd'hui 21 ans est ouverte et trois
sont en projet la protection des enfants
est une priorité dès le plus jeune âge
pour cela dès 2020 un bilan de santé
sera effectué dans toutes les écoles
maternelles du département
chaque année les familles d'accueil et
les structures se voit confier plus de
1000 enfants
c'est pourquoi de nouveau lieu de vie et
d'accueil ouvriront dans le courant de
l'année
à champagné saint-hilaire et à mondiaux
nous soutenons également les mineurs non
accompagnés en leur proposant des
formations en 2010 9 72 contrat jeune
majeur ont été signés l'éducation de nos
enfants est primordial nous avons ajouté
31 millions d'euros au plan collèges
pour permettre la reconstruction du
collège de mirebeau et la restauration
complète du collège descartes
châtellerault les travaux du 35e collège
démarre dès le début de ce premier prix
m
l'objectif est une ouverture en 2021
pour enchaîner avec les travaux du
collège henri iv afin d'impliquer nos
collégiens la vie publique à la création
de projets nous mettrons en place un
conseil départemental des jeunes
nous souhaitons également qu'il puisse
s'épanouir dans le sport est aussi grâce
au label des collèges génération 2024
avec la labellisation terre de jeu le
département porte une réelle ambition
sportive et culturelle
c'est ainsi que l'aréna futuroscope
proposera des concerts et des
manifestations sportives et accueillera
des délégations internationales dans le
cadre des jeux olympiques et
paralympiques 2024 la vienne terre de
sport mais également tourisme
2010neuf nous avons atteint l'objectif
généré 1 milliards de retombées
touristiques sur le territoire nous
avons l'ambition d'aller encore plus
loin avec le plan de développement du
futuroscope véritable moteur du
département l'historial du poitou va
ainsi venir compléter le circuit des
sites touristiques de la vienne cette
historial dont nous allons poser la
première pierre ou au printemps prochain
ouvrira ses portes en avril 2000 22
départements est le premier partenaire
les manifestations culturelles le lien
social tissé lors des événements pour le
succès et le besoin de la culture dans
nos territoires
cette année encore nous poursuivrons les
heures bleues de la vienne et
l'incontournable festival les airs
vagabonde nous poursuivons bien sûr
notre politique d'accès à la culture
avec des dispositifs tels que collège
culture et compagnie et bien sûr toutes
les animations avec bibliothèque
départementale
nous avons besoin d'une agriculture
forte en bonne santé
nous restons nous resterons à côté les
agriculteurs dans les différentes
manifestations telles que la ferme
s'invite ou la conférence départementale
nous avons atteint notre objectif à
gries local 30 % de produits locaux
compose mes repas de nos collégiens
cette année nous ouvrons des commandes
agri locales aux communes afin
d'approvisionner les écoles élémentaires
nous devons être acteur de notre
environnement en 2019 nous avons signé
la charte d'engagement pour le schéma
départemental de l'eau et l'ancien plan
environnemental du département nous
allons faire évaluer notre bilan carbone
développé un plan arbres inciter les
jeunes à découvrir nos espaces naturels
sensibles
nous avons l'obligation de moyens face
de protéger nos concitoyens
cette année nous inaugurerons deux
casernes de poitiers le réaménagement de
gens c'est la construction des trois
moutiers prochaines étapes menant 4 2
fortement gayant population nous avons
mis en place pour accompagner cette
croissance démographique
le schéma départemental de la bi
nous veillons à sa juste répartition sur
tout le territoire
notre objectif mille logements nouveaux
par an la volonté de permettre la
réalisation de projets communaux en 2019
plus de 14 millions de subventions
accordées aux communes ont généré plus
de 100 millions de chiffre d'affaires
pour les entreprises c'est une chance
pour l'emploi notre aéroport de poitiers
biard est un atout majeur d'attractivité
en 2019
nous avons signé avec un nouvel
exploitant dont l'objectif est
d'augmenter le nombre de lits et de
destination nous développons également
l'économie de notre département au
travers le dispositif actif comme vous
le voyez la vienne avance quel chemin
parcouru depuis 2015 sans hausse de
fiscalité depuis quatre ans avec le même
niveau d'investissement avec le maintien
des financements aux communes et pour
les associations
avec vous nous voulons une vienne qui
avance une vienne qui gagne
[Musique]